[Musica]
ciao ragazzi
mister bastoni oggi nuova challenge
trova gli ingredienti slime questa volta
a grandissima richiesta
dovrò trovare gli ingredienti slime
nascosti da hello neighbor non conoscevo
questo personaggio questo videogioco mi
avete chiesto poi di fare un nuovo
episodio trova gli ingredienti slime con
elo naipaul ma è molto inquietante
come avete potuto vedere sono già dovuta
scappare come funziona io dovrò
recuperare gli ingredienti slimer
riuscire a completare e a fare lo slide
prima di essere beccata da elon able lui
in pratica vive dentro la casa e
nasconde degli strani segreti infatti
ogni tanto si sentono dei rumori in quei
bond
io dovrò riuscire a prendere tutti gli
ingredienti e fare lo sly non so se ci
riuscirò perché è molto difficile con
lui non ha l'orecchio super attento come
grilli però se ti rincorre e molto
difficile scappargli tra l'altro è anche
difficile entrare in casa perché lui ha
chiuso quasi tutte le porte e le
finestre
quindi devo riuscire a trovare un
entrata mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi
piace se volete vedere altri episodi
trova gli ingredienti slime in questo
caso se questo video raggiunge i 40 mila
mi piace fare un secondo episodio di
call of naples il video tibaldi
raggiunte 40 mila mi piace infatti tra
poco ne uscirà un secondo episodio
invece quello di credi non ha ancora
raggiunto i 60 mila mi piace infatti
dopo andate a vederlo ea lasciare un bel
mi piace ma ora siete pronti a iniziare
questa avventura assieme
secondo voi ce la farò speriamo teniamo
le dita incrociate e voi dovrete stare
attenti a tutti i rumori perché nel caso
che ci sia qualche indizio nella casa
dovrete poi scriver melo nei commenti
così magari me la caverò meglio al
secondo episodio
siete pronti mettetevi prendete le
patatine pop corn e sperate per me
andiamo dobbiamo trovare un in tram
allora un'altra cosa importante di
questo gioco è che si possono ottenere
gli oggetti e lanciare a lni ball
così magari si può riuscire a scappare
stessi pecca ragazzi invece la corda
però non mi fido entrare d'acqua perché
quindi preferisco l'obelisco cercare
entrata perché sono insicure ok
cerchiamo un altra entrata perché
sicuramente lui si nasconde dietro la
porta con di prima sto scendendo le
scale o rapita se riesco a entrare da
qualche finestra
fatemi sapere se il secondo episodio
preferiti vederlo al buio sarà ancora
più inquietante c'è merlino che fa
rumore comunque qua c'è un'altra entrata
provo a vedere se è aperto ma devo fare
un piano è aperto anche i topi
controlliamo se n'è pure qua dentro
non mi sembra che ci sia
i ragazzi siamo riusciti a entrare o
ancora la palla come
vediamo se troviamo qualche ingrediente
ok abbiamo già perso è molto più
difficile di quello che sembra
ora ci ritroviamo nuovamente fuori
perché ogni volta che si perde in questo
gioco si viene ri catapultati fuori ma
riproviamoci questa volta dobbiamo
essere più silenziosi
c'è una porta chiusa basta
bruno quarta rete alla serratura che
cosa c'era dentro
[Musica]
eccolo lo vedete e luoghi
lo avete visto era lui
quindi meglio non entrare in questa
stanza
vediamo se 4 con qualcosa berlino paesi
lezio sentito il rumore ma guardate
profezia abbiamo trovato l'accordo
quindi abbiamo il nostro primo
ingrediente
ora tocca a trovare anche gli altri però
ok
qua c'è un'altra porta chiusa proviamo a
guardare nella serratura se l nei board
è qui ti amo
cioè non vedo niente berlino fa in
silenzio
non c'è niente
o forse se la chiave per quello che non
si vede niente
ok per fortuna sono riuscita ad aprirla
guardate ci sono delle scale ho paura a
salire le scale berlin continua a fare
un sacco di rumor ma a esplorare questa
zona prima di salire le scale
vediamo
come faccio
[Musica]
come faccio andarli ad esso bellino
merito falliti style time è ridotto a
cui ha dato dignità
a
ragazzi abbiamo perso un'altra volta
non so quante possibilità ho prima di
essere cacciata fuori dal gioco
comunque mi è sembrato di vedere
qualcosa in quella stanza quindi dovremo
sicuramente tornare lì quale sono di
fronte a una porta ma non è la porta in
questione entrata prima
proviamo lo stesso entrare vediamo che
succede qui
[Musica]
per fortuna possiamo mettere colla
ottima cosa ceco ha detto c'è qualcosa
che non va dentro
penso che l unico ha messo del veleno
contempo pensando che io sarei andato a
mangiarlo ma non sono così se ma non
andò mai a mangiare qualcosa da questa
ciotola quindi ora dobbiamo trovare il
modo di sciacquarlo poi la colla dentro
e poi si mancherà solo la soluzione per
lenti e il bicarbonato da trovare forse
solo forza che pratichiamo questa
direzione
qua c'è la porta si fa tutto più buio
[Musica]
sembra che non ci sia nessuno per
fortuna non so in quale stanza andare
beh la colla l'ho lasciata qua quindi è
meglio che vada in una stanza della
folla che i ragazzi mi ha beccato di
nuovo penso di non avere molte altre
possibilità
forse questa è l'ultima o la penultima
non so se riuscirò davvero vincere
questa sfida in sé ma forse se lo posso
ancora fare fate il tifo per me proviamo
a rientrare e questa volta proverò
entrare in un'altra stanza
[Musica]
non c'è nessuno per fortuna
ecco nuovamente la porta chiusa spavento
berlino per trattare la porta perché
vuol evitare un filino è fatto
spaventare
ok
[Musica]
questa è la porta non ho ancora aperto
o no
io sono
[Musica]
si no
sono riusciti a scampare mela per poco
nascondendomi sotto al letto per fortuna
quelli della ciotola che non grassano
prima abbiamo anche la colla eccola qua
però devo ancora trovare la soluzione
per lenti e il bicarbonato spero di
riuscirci marino ma penso che sia un
alleato dirlo nei board perché
continuava appare il rumore in modo che
lui mi trovo quindi devo stare ancora
più attenta
vediamo un po
così questa è una chiave per usarla ma
certo nella stanza chiusa a chiave
ovviamente vantiamo
[Musica]
ok via libera
spero che funzioni
[Musica]
girato e quattro bagni quindi possono
anche sciacquarli da giotto dove sarà
finito
[Musica]
una certa
ok
uccisa chiamo così non può entrare
perché bersagli lonigo e può anche
aprire le porte che ho chiuso a chiave
quindi dimostrare
giusto il tempo stava quasi per beccarmi
il nuovo e forse avrei perso
completamente la sua minaccia non so
come farò siremar
vedremo ora a 4 finalmente
[Musica]
hanno fatto pulitissimo adesso cosa
faccio prima controllo è ancora lì
[Musica]
che cos'era quello forse ancora lo
dietro ma si sta passando cuore un po
soffrire come faccio eccolo lo vedete
[Musica]
scusate ma se anche il gatto che vuole
entrare che sta ci
[Musica]
aiuto ok ho aspettato per un po di tempo
ma qual è il momento di uscire non posso
stare tutto il tempo qualche sei palle
devo fare piave
[Musica]
che i ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta per ora
manca solo il bicarbonato non ha idea di
dove possa essere
spero sia in questa stanza magari provo
a guardare in qualche cassetto in
qualche contenitore qua non c'è niente
[Musica]
aspetta un momento prima la chiave era
quindi potrebbe essere vicino alla
chiave visto che con la chiave ha
trovato la soluzione per lenti quindi
dove potrebbe essere sotto magari dentro
la pianta ma non può essere nella pianta
non c'è momento sbaglio o questo
contenitore meco storto no magari ed è
[Musica]
inutile che controlla anche gli altri
non può essere dentro questi contenitori
però bisogna sempre tentare e non
lasciarsi mai abbattere quindi proviamo
anche co
sto facendo secondarie a mettere il
tutto qua ai ragazzi abbiamo tutto se
riesco ad attivare lo slime abbiamo
vinto allora mattia mondo con questa
bellissima cosa infliggerà ecco fatto
dopodichè mettiamo un po di bicarbonato
[Musica]
assoluzione per lenti forse ci siamo
ragazzi
[Musica]
mescoliamo quando perché non si attiva
non si sta tifando per che non funziona
forse era quella sostanza che c'era
prima nella sotto la mia imbrogliato
non si attiva ancora liquido ragazzi non
so perché ma non si sta attivando bene
forse quella 60 che c'era prima
sta facendo in modo che non si attivi
anche se l'avevo tutta sciacquata nel
lavandino come fare come faccia ad
attivarlo forse devo trovare un altro
ingrediente non lo stop però non si sta
attivando quindi non sai come fare ho
fatto ho detto io lo vivo
rifiuti ha funzionato nonostante lo slam
non fosse completamente attivo perché un
po appiccicoso però almeno funzionato
che non mettono già le 00 il board è
anche perché ultimamente non mi stava
andando molto bene con baldi ho perso se
non l'avete vista andate a vederla dopo
di questa è vero abbiamo vinto ora so di
un bel mi piace per vedere la seconda
parte di neighbor fascista perché i
commenti quali altri sullen se volete
che faccia e ora vi lascio qua 4
caselline su cui andare cliccare per
vedere le nostre altre sale su cremi
baldi headlines challenge cliccate su
quella che preferite è valido reggio